let's talk about where the escalation
has brought us
from fox 4 josh hawley speaks out
arguing biden called him a nazi
when talking to reporters you senator
hawley fired back friday
saying president-elect joe biden
compared him to a nazi propagandist he
didn't say he did
joe biden did from the dallas news joe
biden likens ted cruz to nazi
propagandist goebbels
for helping trump spread big lie about
election fraud it wasn't just cruz
it was also josh hawley now holly's
firing back
saying president-elect biden has just
compared me and another republican
senator to nazis
think about that for a moment let that
sink in
hawley argued he raised lawful questions
about the way elections were conducted
just as democrats did in previous years
but saw a much different outcome
this is undignified immature and
intemperate behavior from the
president-elect
it is utterly shameful he should act
like a dignified adult and retract these
sick comments
the president-elect made the comments
while answering reporters questions in
washington dc friday afternoon
a reporter asked biden if senators holly
and cruz should resign
after a violent mob contesting the
election results stormed the capitol
biden said the two senators should be
flat beaten in their next elections
biden then referred to the big lie and
said that those like
goebbels holly and cruz kept repeating
the lie
goblins was a member of the nazi party
and a reich minister of propaganda under
adolf hitler during world war ii
it's exactly the kind of rhetoric
everybody would want to hear from the
incoming president-elect right the one
who's calling for unity
no this is this is
a level of depravity and insanity i'm so
what should he do in his last few weeks
trump yeah a few days a few days two
days sorry i mean he's getting there i
don't know but they're they said they're
going to impeach him on monday
the democrats are going to impeach him i
don't know if he'll get removed because
if republicans and democrats split 50 50
then mike pence breaks the tie
but what if mitch mcconnell says nah
i'll break the tie and he decides trump
trump's gonna go
you know and then he and then he votes
him out we gonna get any declassified
files no i don't think so i don't trump
has been
unable to get anything declassified they
don't listen to him he's talking about
firing people i don't know what he's
going to do
but listen you know i was mentioning
this earlier
when you have the people who are willing
to walk away kind of conceding with
their tail between their legs and then
you throw something at the back of their
head
this from joe biden is like they're
pouring fuel on the fire
why why would he say this about these
senators
why would why would he tell look it was
over
right right right yeah it's done and
i'll tell you what's what's really crazy
about the scenario
what ted cruz and josh hawley did was
entirely constitutional
yeah they were allowed to do it it was
not out of the ordinary it's happened
before it happened 2005 it happened a
bunch of times
i mean 2016 was crazy and the end result
would have been biden getting
certified as president it would have
given trump supporters their voice
in on on the electoral college count
floor it would have satisfied many not
all
to be like well at least the american
people can hear what we have to say and
we weren't denied that opportunity
now unfortunately it was the trump
supporters who stormed in and
stopped that from happening but to
criticize josh hawley and ted cruz as
though they're
nazi propagandists or in any way like
him simply because they wanted to say
here's what's happening and here's why
we have concerns about this
that's that i think that should be
evidence
that people don't want unity and that
this is likely going to escalate
and escalate faster than you realize it
reminds me about what the nazis did
because they would demonize the
communists and then he's like we need a
new
national crackdown on terrorism those
people are acting like the nazi party
from old it's like that's what the nazis
did to the communists they cracked down
and they said that they were the evil
from you know the
ten years ago in russia or whatever i'm
starting no the first sentence is you're
a nazi the second sentence is unity
everyone come together like really
are you are you really trying to act
like you're you're bringing people
together
if you're using hyperbolic language like
that
well so you we have had for years people
tweeting things about killing nazis and
punching them but then they go and call
literally everyone nazis or compare
everyone to nazis
and so what are people supposed to think
you want to hurt us you want to attack
us because
it's not about attacking nazis it's
about using the worst possible smear you
can against those
you don't agree with that way when you
advocate for some like
listen there are people on twitter who
are saying you know kill nazis or
whatever
twitter allows it then once that's been
approved they then tack onto it here's a
list of who the nazis are and they grab
random people they don't like
and now twitter's approved that so i'll
tell you when when joe biden
says that he says the the protesters are
domestic terrorists
those that stormed the capital he says
these these senators are basically
propagandists for the insurrection the
wall street journal reports
mr biden has said he he plans to make a
priority of pas of a law
a passing a law against domestic
terrorism and he has been
and he has been urged to create a white
house post overseeing the fight against
ideological inspired violent extremists
and increasing funding to combat them
who is it called the enabling act
yeah you know what i said it's gonna be
called like the safe act like securing
american freedoms
you know enhanced the safe act for
everybody
so this is like another homeland
security advise them come on
yeah exactly who did do we have ideas of
who is in his ear right now
he's in his ear he's an establishment a
candidate he's he's a
we've got a lobbyist and he's going not
what they're probably thinking these
establishment people is
once we get power we better make sure
these people never win again and he's
not just talking about trump he's
talking about bernie sanders too
and that's why i think it's hilarious
many of these left just walked right
into this
it should have been obvious i said it if
if the establishment gets back in
they're going to lock the doors
and no populist will ever see it whether
it's left or right
yeah they would do the same thing to
cortez i would think um
maybe because it's trying to play the
game right now calling for people's
censorship another
scary aspect of this is that you know
biden he kind of showed that he's not
really there
he's he's not on it he doesn't have the
ball
in front of him it looks like someone
else has the ball
and is carrying this whole program here
when you look at his speech when you
look at his mindset
competent doesn't come to mind and when
you have that
you also understand that this is the
person that sold out to the special
interest
almost more than any other president
before him he argued with barack obama
saying that there needs to be more
special interest
inside of the obama administration and
obama had to tell him
no so when we have big tech executives
inside of the biden administration
goldman sachs the military-industrial
complex
and you have unlimited power you look at
that entire recipe
there's no one or nothing that could
check him another thing that i kind of
wanted to bring up is that if if you
remember chuck schumer
literally brought up that if you mess
with the i this is not his exact phrase
but he said
when donald trump messes with the
intelligence agencies they have six ways
to sunday
to get back at him so i also in relation
to that i also want to bring up this cb
cbs news article that is literally
titled social media is a tool
of the cia seriously that is the title
of their article on cbs news and they
start off by saying quote you don't need
to wear tin foil hat
to believe that the cia is using
facebook twitter google
and other social media companies to spy
on people that's because the cia
published a helpful list of press
releases
on all the social media ventures it
sponsors
via its technology investment firm in
qtel so again that's that's the firm
that i brought up here previously before
so there is a lot of things to talk
about there there's a lot of room for
kind of speculation here even though i
don't like doing that but we have to
understand when we look at these big
tech
companies they're not just outside
entities outside of the government
they are entities that work with the
government hand in hand
not just spying on you but in more
severe ways than we even know
and this is truly an emerging power that
that can't be
unchecked at amazon it's not considered
a social network but they have that 100
computer that everyone's got people have
in their house that you can command and
listen
well this is another thing with amazon
with amazon they're working
they're working on new uh technology
that will break
encryption they're working on oh they've
got it yeah well
they do yeah they also well quantum
supremacy you know you know about this
right bill yeah but i don't think it's
it's we don't know the exact level we
don't know the exact details here they
were heavily criticized for
developing facial recognition technology
that was used by ice
but that's only just the tip of the
iceberg here literally
uh comparatively to all the other big
deep state projects that they're working
on
that they're developing that need to be
brought up have you seen go big show
on tbs uh we were slowly i was watching
two minutes
why can't you just let them have the
power
didn't you want to see the man do the
backflip on the tricycle the man was too
busy working out
there was another guy i heard luke who
got a football to the groin
interesting yes wouldn't you much rather
just order a pizza sit back watch the
football
groin show and leave the democrats to to
have their power and what them do they
want wasn't that in
idiocracy where they had a show where
the guy was just getting getting hit
in the balls did really the show that
you were watching was there really a
segment where they had okay oh
i wouldn't be surprised i wouldn't be
surprised either yeah idiocracy man mike
judge nailed it
yeah i mean to be to be honest donald
trump's in the wwe hall of fame
and then camacho the president was a
wrestler so even buddha is coming back i
heard
right well it comes back every so often
doesn't it yeah i think we're
we're headed for dark days man because
what's happening is happening faster and
faster and what we saw at the capitol
was
i don't you know i think in terms of the
political ramifications it was serious
and the craziest thing is when you look
at photos and there's like there's a
photo going around a guy with zip tie
handcuffs
and people are like what were they
planning on doing with that like taking
hostages
and then there's a picture of a grandma
who's just like waving a little flag and
she has no idea what's going on
it's really really weird what we're
seeing but the media is treating this
like the apocalypse
it's exactly what the left the
establishment the cultural institutions
needed
to take action to start purging
everybody yeah so now they're now
there were reports earlier before the
show that uh steve bannon's show has
been deleted from youtube
so i think you know they said it was for
election related misinformation
yep uh that wouldn't surprise me and
there's a very famous meme going around
now
that says quote we spend 750 billion
dollars
annually on defense and the center of
american government fell in two hours
to the duck dynasty and the guy in the
chewbacca bikini and they have a photo
of
of the you know the guys in costume you
know
you know it's really funny as this purge
is going on i do think some people are
leaving twitter
that they're deactivating their accounts
and they're going to parlor because the
president has been removed
but i think a lot of people are being
banned and a lot of people are noticing
i think it's probably a lot of people
purposefully leaving i wonder if the
majority is as actual bannings
but my twitter following is like it goes
down and it spikes really high because i
like i'll tweet something and then
the people who remain will start
following me but then as people are
leaving it goes down
a lot of people are down like i saw one
tweet just now sixteen
thousand people yes julian assange's uh
mother just tweeted that she lost
six thousand followers just now this is
a mass purge this can't just be people
leaving
twitter is going through networks
they're probably looking at a network
and just removing they said they were
going through rudy giuliani's
well so so there's a there's a twitter
bot that
will tell you when someone in the trump
network follows or unfollows and it was
this
massive lift saying rudy giuliani
unfollowed this person and this person
and just huge list of people saying rudy
giuliani unfollowed these people and i'm
like
did twitter just pull up rudy giuliani's
following list
and just delete everybody he followed
because
i was trying to protect people maybe no
i don't know rudy giuliani is fighting
for trump
so i removed this when i was down there
in the bathroom i just thought about
that we need to break up these
corporations again this is this monopoly
on public speech and i just don't see a
value to shattering the corporations
into a bunch of
proprietary networks like why would we
break facebook into facebook prime and
instagram again that zuckerberg owns
both of the code is still
so i keep going back to the way we would
break up a social network's monopoly is
by freeing their software code
after they reach a certain level of user
base and people's argument is
why would i give up my work for all this
my life's work if i've attained 100
million followers now
i lose my code and i'm like well your
code going free doesn't mean you lose
the network you still own facebook
you still can profit off of all that
activity on facebook but the code
yeah your code should be like an idea i
think it should be open sourced and i
think if we did have open source
technology the world would be a lot
better and freer
and the network effects that you can
achieve my opinion the networks
network effects and growth you can
achieve not to mention because your
community will trust you more now
because you're being transparent with
them but it's it's
the reason bitcoin is exploding right
now is because
it's open there's not going to be a
closed system but i i understand that
you guys view the code as
our code i think that sometimes the code
can be my code and you're all just dirty
commies who think that
and i actually believe in private
property so i disagree uh but in all
seriousness
no i think there can be i think a lot of
things need to be open depending on what
they are
probably social media if it's something
that has a serious impact on our
politics
civics then we should probably
understand how that works but if it's a
proprietary service i don't think that
code should be
forced like a city no not forced but
like it's in
your interest to do it like voting
yes absolutely how they're working why
they're working we should be able to
watch
because think about it this way if we
could see the voting counting going in
real time and how the code worked
and then something weird happened and a
vote flipped everybody would see it
the problem i guess is that it's
connected to the internet but then
everyone's watching it you know what i
mean so
i don't know there's there's there's
challenges to this it's just
accountability why can't we have
accountability we should have
accountability for
so many different things in our society
that would clear things up
if you're gonna say that there was
russian collusion with donald trump
show us the evidence it took them a
while to reveal
absolutely nothing and then in the
meantime they slandered and discredited
and threw people
under the the bus including myself and
we are changed
we're talking about you know the voting
that just happened be transparent
do investigations look into it show us
the evidence uh
again that would have proved and solved
so much angst that would have proved and
solved so much of the uncertainty
and and and again when these companies
make these
large decisions banning people
destroying people's voice
they're doing it in a way where there's
no accountability for that
there's no way to appeal it we don't
even know why the decision was made we
don't know exactly
what even led up to it it's just a
totalitarian saying that's it
i get my way i don't even have to say
why i did what i did
and that's a dangerous unaccountable
power that
surely i was i was saying this years ago
is going to be abused is being abused
right now a lot of people want to talk
about
civil war and stuff and they think the
right has some tremendous advantage
because they're the tough guys because
they're the survivalists and all that
stuff but i said listen man
they'll sever the lines of communication
in two seconds before any
anything starts and then you'll be
sitting there looking at your phone
saying i wonder what's going on
the lines of communications are being
severed it's it's what they're doing
yeah zuckerberg is kind of like a mayor
of a city of a town
and and right now it's like a private
town like a mayor well it's kind of like
he's more like an internet mayor or
internet governor
well have you ever seen those old
westerns where like the the guy rides
into the town and he's like it's my time
exactly sheriff you work for me it's my
town now and he owns the town so our
government is in place to make sure that
no individual
owns these cities like no one owns new
york it's
controlled by all of us and i think that
facebook has gotten to the strength of
power well someone governs it that's put
into power
be real though by us look at look what
de blasio is doing legally look his
wife's got a two million dollar staff
while the city the way the law is built
i'm just talking about i get it is that
i think that facebook is powerful enough
that in influential enough that we
should treat it like a city
and not not a a piece of of ownership of
something that someone can own
i'm just talking about the code he can
still own the domain and people can
still use facebook and he can have
stores and everything twitter twitter
can be
publicly owned and open with guaranteed
rights
and we don't need to worry about making
money on or they could have utility it
could still be
private and all the code could be a
utility that we could build another
network that is a utility with the same
code
that could integrate with twitter yes
and because if you shatter it into a
bunch of proprietary networks it
wouldn't stop the monopoly on the
behavior
right what what i think we need
platforms that are free speech
you know open publicly owned and that's
just me look maybe i'm lefty yeah
taxpayer funded nationalized with
guaranteed rights you break the law
someone reports you it's a criminal
offense you broke the law
if you say a nasty opinion you block
them and say i don't want to see you
that's simple
what do you do harassment laws apply
well harassment is a crime
this is how the big networks grew under
that
premise mostly i mean their content
policies were already were always pretty
restrictive like you know but to a
certain degree
they rode the whole wave of letting
people
say most of what was okay and now
they're doing the bait and switch
that's a big problem too is that you can
make a company make it huge and popular
and then sell it to some
totalitarian dictator and then all of a
sudden 100 million people are now being
driven by this this guy that now owns
the city you basically handed the keys
of the city to this next guy so yeah i
agree i don't think that
these networks should be controlled by
the bait and switch the
but even the potential for the bait and
switch shouldn't exist yeah
and do god no no you're not i'm gonna
change the subject
yeah there's you would just expect that
executives with billions of dollars
thousands of developers
at their disposal could come up with
realistic problems for breaking echo
chambers like okay
here's recommendations of stuff that you
might disagree with or from people from
the other side of the spectrum
here's recommendations for this here's
how to curate your algorithm so you know
so you're getting a balanced diet of
information like they just literally
it is intentional but you know the
problem with that is for like twitter
is that if you're somebody who's like if
is a far leftist
and they say why don't you follow tim
poole he's a you know moderate
individual who
believes in free speech and liberty then
they're going to start spamming me and
insulting me and
it's going to be really annoying the
problem is ultimately in the end
you have uh you have many different
kinds of people but there seems to be
two overarching kinds of people the if
someone is bothering me i'll block them
group and the if someone's bothering me
i demand twitter block them from
everyone group
and so there's no negotiating i it's one
of the things that i think jack dorsey
actually said
in one of his testimony in his senate
testimony he was like
we have people who are demanding on the
left that we ban people for this reason
and then the right demands that we don't
ban them for this reason and we have to
figure out like we have these both you
know both groups screaming in our ears
now i guess ultimately because the
cultural institutions and the media are
controlled by the left
these big tech companies know exactly
who butters their bread they want to
sell advertisements right
well if a news story comes out the wall
street journal that youtube does bad
then youtube says we're so sorry wall
street journal please
and then they they cave that's what
happened with pewdiepie in the first ad
pocalypse
and the crazy thing is these news
outlets know youtube is their
competition
so they're doing it on purpose for
probably for now for financial gain but
they also learn that people like to hear
their own thoughts regurgitated
to them so they created echo chambers
through the algorithm and i remember
back in the day when the internet
was still amazing in a beautiful place
and was a free place because it didn't
have any algorithms
it didn't have any news feeds it didn't
have any curated
timelines with these corporations
deciding what you should hear
if you would subscribe to something you
would actually see it you would actually
hear it
this curation has essentially led to
these larger echo chambers to these
larger
to these larger radicalizations and have
pushed people further and further apart
on the political spectrum
where now we are in a situation where
people are at each other's throats
and we have to wake up and realize that
this was done by social media
so what makes you think giving all your
power to social media
is going to fix it this is such a
frustrating thing
you see the direct fingerprint whether
it's
the mental health crisis whether it's
the algorithm whether it's the echo
chambers
whether it's them colluding with
intelligence agencies and government
agencies
when you see this problem and and they
they they have
they're a part of it and now you have
people saying they're going to fix it
all if you just give them all of your
power
and people are falling for it
celebrating this today you got to be
freaking kidding me it's like the
monkey's paw you know that story it's
like you get three wishes
but then it twists your wish these
leftists are like yeah censorship yeah
they're gonna get this are all the bad
people and that definition of bad it's
like a twilight zone episode
where it's like it was time now it's not
fair it's like why am i being banned
no everyone was finally banned and i
could finally have peace and then
they're they're glad
they dropped their phone and the phone
shatters no you know you know that
episode no that sounds
like that it's the episode where the guy
like just wants to read and the world
ends when he breaks his glasses yeah
he's got big thick glasses so i'm
imagining it's like a leftist
demanding everyone be banned and then
finally once everyone's banned he has
his phone he's like now i can look and
he drops his phone no
well information people need to
understand information is key during war
one of the first things that was done
during the iraq war from some of the
reports that i heard from frontline
soldiers is that there was leaflets
dropped on populations yeah of course
saying americans are coming they're here
to liberate you and here to free you
so this has been done as a part of
psychological warfare many times
throughout many important battles
and this is in the information were
ramping up to
huge just astronomical levels where
even fifth generational warfare doesn't
put a candle to it to what's happening
now and that's another term that people
should look up and should research
themselves when they want to understand
what is deeply happening and what is
going to happen from here in vietnam
they used to blast
uh audio in the jungle this like demonic
sounds
no no no no no no no and it would scare
the vietnamese because they were they
were all emotional
and they wouldn't come out that night no
i got to correct you talk about
informational warfare it was just like
let me let me you know medulla oblongata
let me correct you please do
during vietnam the u.s would blast audio
of wailing
vietnamese saying why did i do it i made
a mistake
run while you still can or you'll be
trapped here for eternity like i am
because their religious belief was that
if they weren't properly buried
they were trapped to rome the area where
they died forever
the problem was it was too effective and
the south vietnamese i believe was the
south who was working with us
panicked and ran when they heard it but
imagine you're in the jungle in the dead
of night with your gun
and then you hear a wailing ghostly
voice crying and begging you saying
don't become trapped like i am run while
you still can
psychological warfare is crazy stuff man
it's like it's you know you know that
old fake story about the general and the
pig's blood
apparently it's not a real story but
they they talk about this this uh
general who after killing a bunch of you
know like uh
muslim soldiers in the middle east
poured pig's blood on them
and left one alive and let him leave so
that he went and told them and then they
all stopped fighting i believe that
story's not true but people tell that
all the time the idea being that
he's like oh no it's you know this is
bad it's against the religion and so he
panicked told everyone and then they
refused to engage
psychological warfare oh you know what
simple pen is mightier than the sword
well that's what they say the first step
in it is to control communication once
you control communication once you
control what people can and cannot
listen to you have a such a severe
advantage
over your supposed enemies or even
someone you think
are the nazis you know what trump's
mistake was he didn't watch revenge of
the sith
okay because i just watched revenge of
the sith that was his and you know you
know what palpatine did
smart palpatine feigned
a assassination attempt you know when
mace window comes in
and then anakin's there and then he's
like don't let them kill me i'm too weak
and then anakin you know ends up killing
mace windu and everything
i'm kidding by the way but it is like
you know
trump is sitting there i think i don't
think trump had uh to be honest
they're saying trump incited in all this
stuff i don't i don't think so i don't
think trump intended for this to happen
when we had we had jack murphy on
recently and he was saying that it
sounded like when trump was giving a
speech it was a concession speech
he said sometimes it takes more courage
to do nothing and he was like what does
that mean you know
like trump was trying to wind things
down well he said it's going to be up to
mike pence
yeah so like he he made sure he had no
responsibility
at all and everyone was like okay let's
see what mike pence is going to do and
he
released that statement which um sat
around
somebody somebody tweeted something
really funny they said how long until
trump uses the presidential alert system
to send him back i was just thinking
about that when he tweet he's gonna
presidential alert his new
parlor account yes well there's even
there's even some scuttlebutt
of them creating their own social media
networks well he said that that's
yeah that's what they should do they
should use the minds code they should
take
the codes there the code build your own
network with mine's code a government
site man more diversity i mean tim
you've known you've known to back up
your social situation
the whole time yeah you have to you have
to protect yourself and the fact that
you know he didn't it's thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you
all next time